is everybody calling you coach now
yeah like um like it doesn't really
matter but coach has a good
coach cal has a really good ring to it
and like the leader so i really like the
name coach talent fits well there um i
like coaches are leaders and they coach
people to get people motivated so a lot
of people are calling me coach kyle
right now absolutely i love it i like
what's how's the reaction been from
everybody like your family and friends
after you were on ellen what did they
say to you
oh it was just an awesome
like they were saying like good job and
they were all like supporting me this
whole time so i
i gave big thank yous to them because
they've been supporting me a lot because
um they've been um watching and doing
all that stuff they've been helping us
and they've been doing a lot of
supporting this whole time so
the reaction was just um
awesome because like they've been
helping us all this time it
it's it was just awesome
that's great hey are you wearing the the
gift that she gave you is that what
you're wearing right now
yeah i'm wearing the coach cal track
suit um
i i it's really i really like it so this
is my coach cal jackson um
my um
colin and yeah and then my coat
that yeah i'm going to sing
that's awesome do you wear it like every
day now
well like
like
most my interviews lately like um i i've
been wearing it so like it's a pretty
big big hit for the interviews right now
listen if i got a gift like that i'd be
wearing it every day i'd be wearing it
to sleep i'd be wearing it to work i'd
wear it all the time it's great it looks
good on you
you know it's it's not every day you're
welcome it's not every day that a
canadian kid gets to go on ellen like
that what was your reaction when you
found out they wanted to see you and
meet you
oh i was just so excited mama just came
out
off the phone out of her bedroom and
then she just made me do a video like
and once she told me i just was just
like this is so awesome like i'm going
to like los angeles to give that speech
to ellen and when i was giving the
speech talent i felt so good because um
ellen's like a one of the biggest talk
shows and um when i went on it i just
felt so like
awesome that i was giving that speech
and getting her motivated for the final
season just felt awesome
now you had her in tears like you had
her crying and the whole audience was
give you a standing ovation how did that
feel
well when she was in tears and i it
meant a lot and like because we i would
really hurt on that speech and
we um
it meant a lot for us and our family
just because um
she's like i i want to figure out a
speech that would be the best
to make ellen
to make ellen motivated for last season
and it happened so when she cried it
meant a lot just to
when i gave the speech and after it and
it just meant a lot because uh we worked
really hard on that speech
that's awesome it seems like you you
work really hard on them do you practice
quite a bit before you give your
speeches
yeah i like it getting like prepared and
prepped because like i want to get
people motivated in my hand movements to
like get people motivated and like to
practice a couple times so then when i'm
giving it to people i can get people
motivated and
looking at them like to get the them
motivated just by like getting staying
positive and just stay
calm like staying with confidence and it
happened and
this is like i want my speeches to be
the best and
because i just look so hard at them
so would you say coach cal that the the
secret to giving a good motivational
speech is like
to get people there get their eye
contact
and to get them going like what's the
what's the best advice that you can give
to someone that wants to give good
motivational speeches
well i well i'd love to give the secret
to you guys this basically the secret is
to like do you like you gone and know
that your speech will be the best and
you gotta stay comfortable and confident
and staying positive that you will know
but your speech will be awesome in it
and like everybody and
and everybody will enjoy because you
have because you have to put time into
it and make those words that will fit
into that speech to get people
motivated and the secret is like i have
like this one line and then i always say
it is we're gonna do whatever it takes
to get the w go out there to get the dub
and get the w that is the line that i
always have to say because uh that is my
favorite one did i say in the speech so
that's one that's my secret line and
that was that's the secret
where did get the w come from
well like what like one day like um
we're in the car and like we were
thinking of our speech for repeats and
we're like well we need to figure out
something for repeat a new speech so we
figured and we were like what about we
and we're like saying what we're gonna
do whatever it takes to get the win or
like well maybe that's a little too long
so we say i said oh oh maybe we're gonna
do whatever it takes to get to w like
yeah that's a motivating line and people
love that and once i once we thought of
that one that was and that was pretty
awesome and uh that's my favorite line
now
i love it i think that's my favorite
line now too get the w do whatever it
takes to get the w coach cal who
who do you want to give a motivational
speech to next like who do you think
could use your
uh your particular brand of like
get out there go get the w who do you
want to give a motivational speech to
well i i
i love giving like speeches to my family
and all that stuff but i really i'm like
connor mcdavid he gets me motivated i
love watching him and he always gets me
motivated i want to look like him always
so i would love to like give him a
motivative speech to get him going as
well because he is my favorite hockey
player he always works hard so i want to
look like him every 9am out there so um
i would love to give one to conor
mcdavid
i love that i'm sure i'm sure he's
paying attention i'm sure conor mcdavid
knows and connor dave is probably ready
so you're telling me that you give
motivational speeches to your family
like you give like motivational speeches
to your mom like when do you give a
motivational speech to your mom like if
you're having like tough times and like
i really need to like my all my like my
family members when they're going
through tough times like my grandma and
papa we take videos and send them to
them like little like
good lines that will get them motivated
for anything like sometimes when they're
about to do something i give them like
some motivated words to go out there and
do your best and get the w i i really
like all my family members like even
when i'm in my house when they went for
a tough time i say some like they asked
me like what like
you know you can could you give a speech
to them and like i'm like oh yeah i'd
love to and then i give speeches to my
family
do you ever give a motivational speech
to anyone in your family when they're
like sleeping in a little bit too late
in the morning
yeah that yeah um i have to keep quiet
on that one i have to keep i have to
stay quiet but um i am an ugly wise and
they
they like sleeping in so um
much on that one but um
i'm sure they'll appreciate it hey
before we go
i would love
if
for et canada like what would you have
to say to us
if what could you give us in terms of a
motivational speech or some words of
wisdom coach cal
um i would love to give a little speech
to you if um that would be awesome
yeah i would love that
okay
whatever you want me to start
anytime
okay
every day is a great day and every day
we have to work hard and keep staying
positive because we all
every day counts and we all
and we all have to get the w today and
every day so how are we gonna do that we
have to stay positive and and do our
best always because every day is a new
day and we and we give it all
every day
so let's go out there and get the w and
do our best keep working hard and
staying positive every day so let's go
out there and give it our all
and let's bake the best of it during
this tough time
so let's go out there and get the w food
it's tough time
let's go canada
you got it buddy that was awesome hey
thank you so i am inspired by you my
friend thank you so much it was great to
meet you
oh thank you i was so excited to give
back to you it was awesome nice meeting
you was so i'm so excited to be on this
thank you so much
you